il y a des drames qui se passent minutes
toutes les
minutes voilà au Proche Orient on le
sait hier plusieurs centaine de
personnes ont été tué dans la frappe sur
l'hôpital de la ville de Gaza 200 à 500
selon les sources dans un hôpital sur
place c'est un drame les dégâts de
l'explosion sont impressionnants et bien
sûr les Palestiniens sont
désespérés et bah
forcément c'est un drame et le drame il
se joue là-bas il ne se joue pas ici
c'est ça que je voudrais dire euh aux
gens qui mettent des messages sur les
réseaux le drame il se joue là-bas il
nous ici on a la chance d'avoir une vie
exceptionnelle voilà alors bien sûr il y
en a qui galèrent plus que d'autres qui
ont des vie difficiles aussi ici mais
là-bas même la vie la plus difficile ici
est plus facile que la meilleure vie de
de ce que ces gens vivent hier encore
euh dans un hôpital explosion alors il y
a deux versions ça qui est fou c'est Mo
moi moi je vous dis je comprends plus
rien euh deux versions sur sur sur cette
sur ce terrible drame on va voir les les
dégâts et je vous dis moi quand je vois
ça voilà c'est c'est c'est dramatique
c'est c'est des images qui restent dans
la tête toute la journée que vous avez
dû avoir vous aussi dans dans votre tête
toute la journée la détresse les dégâts
et bien sûr que comme on a dit il faut
dissocier
euh les les les civils des deux côtés en
prennent plein la gueule en ce moment et
ils vivent des moments effroyables et
les civils ils ont envie que d'une chose
je crois maintenant c'est de dire nous
on a envie de vivre une vie tranquille
d'être en paix arrêtez avec la politique
le ne croyez pas beaucoup d'Israéliens
aussi c'est comme si ici tout le monde
n'est pas derrière Emmanuel Macron et
bien là-bas tout le monde n'est pas
derrière le Premier ministre israélien
loin s'en faut regardez nous avons
ressenti qu'il y avait le feu et que les
choses nous tombaient
dessusous ont commencé à nous appeler
soudain l'électricité a été coupée et
nous ne pouvions plus nous
voir regardez tous ces gens morts ce
sont des civils ils n'ont aucune
arm environ 3000 personnes s'étaient
réfugié ici nous étions en train de
soigner les gens dans l'hôpital quand
tout à coup sans aucune alerte nous
avons été pris pour
quel drame vraiment c'est un drame de de
de voir ça alors l'histoire c'est que
Jacques ce qui est fou c'est qu'il y a
deux versions il y a une version qui dit
la version du hamaas et la version
d'Israël et Joe Biden Joe Biden a donné
sa version lui aussi qu'on va voir dans
un instant c'est quoi les deux versions
B ce qu'il faut dire c'est que pour le
moment on ne sait pas quelle est
l'origine ti de roqu a le ce tir de
roquette il y a il y a il y a a deux
versions les Gazaouis disent accusent
Israël et Israël croit savoir et croit
avoir des éléments publics c'est ce
qu'ils ont dit dès ce matin que c'était
une erreur de tir qui provenait du
Djihad islamique qui est un groupe
terroriste qui est on va dire cousin du
Hamas en tous les cas proche du Hamas
donc voilà ces deux versions Alour Joe
Biden euh il a ce matin dit qu'il
croyait à la version regardez ce qu'il a
dit regardez j'aité
infligé de la perte de vie récente dans
cet hôpital nous pensons que cela
résulté d'une requête tiré depuis Gaza
j'ai demandé au membres des ministre
régalien de renforcer l'aide humanitaire
à
Gaza j'annonce de nouveau financement de
100 milliards de dollars en soutien des
gaz
ce qui est fou je vous dis ça cette
histoire elle résume je vous dis elle
résume tout c'estàdire que il y a
aujourd'hui on sait pas d'où
vientir on va le savoir là très vite
voilà
apparemmentuttre sourit
d' des mecs a des civils qui étai dans
un
hôpitalu on sait on sait même pas d'où
ça vient non mais est-ce que vous rendez
compte de ça est-ce que vous rendez
compte donc il il y a des gars qui
s'envoi des missiles et au milieuureus
non mais franchement et on ne sera sans
doute jamais cyil he parce qu'il
faudrait une enquête indépendante est-ce
que lui il a dit c'est le camp d'en face
lui c'est team l'équipe adverse bah
sous-entendu pour lui c'est plutôt
l'équipe adverse donc ça viendrait
plutôt av une base de lancement juste
derrière l'hôpital et en fait la version
d'Israël c'est qu'en fait ils ont lancé
il qui a fait feu n pas parti là où
devait partir et qui est retombé
beaucoup plus trop tôt qui retombé juste
sur l'hôpital qui était juste à côté av
Unop
court donc c'est pas pas sera une er
tout ça conditionnel tu dis information
chasse une information et il faut faire
gaffe
àon voit c'est le résultat regardez
quand on voit ces gens en détresse mais
ça c'est F vous croyez qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont à [__] de savoir d'où ça vient ce
qu' disent c'est que leur vie est brisé
voilà c'est c'est il y a rien de pire
ils sont l'enjeu d'une guerre de
communication qui a commencé hier soir
où donc dans un premier temps c'est
plutôt le côté palestinien qui a semblé
prendre si je puis dire en terme de
communication le dessus et puis les
Israéliens sont arrivés avec ce qu'ils
démontrent comme étant des preuves des
enregistrements audio des vidéos mais
nous nous ne pouvons pas savoir d' alors
même la chaîne on dit que même la chaîne
aljazira a dit que c'était une
requêteam Israël qui écoute évidemment
tout ce qui se passe dans la bande de
Gaza et ils ont des systmécout trs
perfen il
onécoute sold du Hamas
dis VI chez nous c'est une
erreil vous
plationil vous platre entre les de
dirigantsil vous plission
merci
لامقى Mo je vais vous dire quoi qu'il
arrive on condamne bien sûr ce qui s'est
passé voilà voilà et et on pense surtout
aux victimes et on en a le cul voilà je
vous le dis j'ai des mots voilà qui
comme ça parce que j'en a à le cul de
voir des victimes tous les jours que ce
soit d'un côté ou de l'autre et quand je
vois ces personnes dans une détresse
incroyable croyez pas qu'ils a ils ont
des vies de fous toute l'année où il où
il kiffent la vie hein je vous le dis
voilà c'est c'est c'est une détresse
voilà absolu tout le temps et en plus il
se retrouve au milieu voilà d'un conflit
les gars ils veulent juste vivre voilà
je vous le dis et même pas survivre
d'ailleurs ils veulent même pas vivre il
veulent survivre il faut rappeler Cyril
que en principe une guerre elle a des
codes et c'est une ce sont des armées
qui s'affrontent ou des groupes armé qui
s'ffrontent apparemment c'est une erreor
puisque le missile est tombé mais ce que
je voulais dire c'est qu'en principe la
Convention de Genève elle encadre les
conditions de la guerre et là on est
hors cadre puisque on sait bien que le
Hamas n'est pas une entité et et n'a pas
n'a pas attaqué des militaires côté
israélien et de l'autre côté maintenant
les Israéliens s'ils veulent pouvoir
roster il faut que les civils de de Gaza
évacuent et donc on voit bien qu'on est
dans quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir
avec ce qu'on considère être une guerre
conventionnelle donc voilà et et après
il faut aussi faire très attention parce
que toutes les manipulations en image
sont possibles toutes les versions sont
possibles et oui des deux côtés
absolument et les les l'enquête elle
sera extrêmement difficile alors
peut-être que cette conversation sera
déterminante mais mais pour que une
enquête puisse se faire il faut que les
deux parties puissent être sur place et
contreenquêter qui est également
des contreenquêter rendez contre
ou
hôent Miss et derère on
contreenquter pour éviter aussi un
embrasement de T les
Arab exactement après c'est vrai que
voilà après la chaîne j'ai vu aljazira
ils ont montré des images de
vidéosurveillance qui montrent que
l'explosion je sais pas j'ai vu ces
images là qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de
ces images elles sont fiables ou pas non
mais c'est c'est là où il faut attendre
avir c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr donc
qui détermine
tout ça il y a des grosses enquêtes qui
sont mis en place et puis puis pour
essayer de savoir ce qui s'est passé
mais encore une fois et dans toutes les
guerres conventionnelles comme tu dis
ceux qui mchent ce sont toujours les
civils he toutes les guerres depuis 14
parce que c'est un hôpital ce sont des
civils c'est absolument atroce Absolum
et et et l'impact que ça a en France
aussi en France et en Europe parce que
on voit ce qui se passe le le le niveau
de terrorisme en France et au somome
l'unité de coordination de lutte
terroriste boss comme des malades nuit
et jour pour essayer de déjouer les
attentats on sait qu'il y en a plus de
40 qui ont été jouer donc il y a un vrai
boulot qui est fait en France et c'est
un risque évident pour tous nos
compatriotes on va pas [__] la
trouille à tout le monde mais bon d'être
vigilant pour l'instant oui bien
sûr surtout à ces gens qui sont des deux
côtés qui sont sous les les bombes et
sous les missiles et qui j'ai eu un moi
il y a un truc de fou qu'il avait un on
m'a raconté un truc voilà il y avait des
des gens qui étaient dans un hôtel des
des journalistes étaient dans un hôtel
et je sais pas pourquoi on leur a dit
changer d'hôtel voilà dès ce so soir je
sais pas pourquoi le lendemain matin
l'hôtel avait été bombardé rasé rendez
comp qu' sont passés à ça il y a plein
de cas comme ça il y a plein de choses
qui se passent et sachez-le là-bas c'est
c'est c'est c'est un chaos total et
voilà alors nous on est là en train de
dire tiens qui c'est là c'est là c'est
là nous on est bien on est bien
tranquille ici on reçoit trois trois
trois menaces sur les réseau on flippe
voilà on se dit ah c'est compliqué et
cetera mais sachez que la viille là-bas
est très très très compliqué et qu'elle
va être de plus en plus compliqué c'est
ça qui qui nous angoisse parce que on
veut voir on n pas envie de voir des
gens souffrir ici des civils souffrir
des deux côtés et je pense en plus que
ce qui est fou une fois de plus c'est
que ce sont les les politiqu qui qui se
parlent les politiques les les les
terroristes mais si on a laissé les les
les civils se parler on trouverait des
solutions beaucoup plus rapidement je
pense et c'est ça et et c'est vrai que
là la solution là trouve de moins en
moins et voilà et donc aujourd'hui on
est dans un file quand tu vois ça c'est
c'est normal je suis d'accord avec vous
aujourd'hui la la la diplomatie c'est
presque fini quoi Joe Biden il est venu
ça ne servait à rien un sommet qui a été
annulé donc là maintenant on a
presque de camp face- à face armé sur le
pied de guerre et et là ça risque d'être
épouvantable même si dérisoire ils ont
accepté quand même d'ouvrir un couloir
humanitaire ça quand même une av
grâce à la venue de de Biden qu mais
c'est vrai que voilà là en tout cas
voilà
y a deux en tout cas Joe Biden donc lui
est-ce que vous pensez que le président
américain prendrait le risque de de
donner une fausse info dites la vérité
non non non non de toute manière les
infos il les a des du secret de service
fait Secret Service de la CIA et autres
donc c'est c'est ces services qui lu don
des informations est-ce qu'ell son bonne
ou pas c'est tout le problème de la
diplomatie de toutes les informations
que veulent faire passer les états soit
le RAM soit le sbola un d'autrre moment
soit soit l'état israélien chacun donne
sa versionud les images du drone
exactement non mais c'est c'est juste
voilà donc c'est un autre groupe
terroriste euh qui serait aussi
peut-être Jihad islamique ouai alors il
faut voir aussi ce que Biden a dit
officiellement conférence de presse est
ce qu'il a dit en tête à-tête au premier
ministre israélien peut-être qu'il a eu
une version un peu divergente en le
plaçant face à des responsab c'est
possible ça il y a le langage policé de
il semble que ça vienne du camp d'en
face je crois savoir dans son dans sa
conférence de presse qu'il dit selon les
éléments qui sont à ma possession c'est
une phrase typique dans les langages
diplomatiques qui montrent que à ce
stade c'est ce qu'il sait alors est-ce
que ça se base effectivement sur des
cartographies des images satellites et
qu'ils ont déjà la provenance c'est
facile s'ils ont la provenance du tir et
qu'elle se situe entre la mer et
l'hôpital c'est forcément que ça vient
de ce côté-là de Gaza en revanche si ça
n'est pas le cas on le saura aussi
évidment donc j'ai envie de dire là
aussi il faut qu'on ait des preuves
parce qu'il faut aussi calmer les
opinions partout des deux côtés euh on
va se retrouver dans un instant